oh I can customize yeah but your face
that's it all right people I'm Annessa
my this feeling make him go in the night
and the moonlights yet make them as
white as I am given that Irish paint
can't take in the air there's a gate
that hires change that hot Irish to eat
it smells like bagua hood okay who are
we picking yeah oh no I still get joined
for [ __ ] sakes
great choice Bob two holes no pump
thinking ah hell yeah time I heard that
in bed to say you got a long bet you
really got to work it all right okay I
have to equip things right health
beverage I want to have beverage health
this [ __ ] wait the project Anderson home
your loadout what the [ __ ] is this yeah
okay calm down
who's that one team who's Oscar Tony on
a pirate ship it's really loud here I
can't join my football in okay wait
let's go in the footage
oh wait let's join the British oh I just
got almost YouTube ah damn it
I just roll oh we are in the USS
Harbinger hang on wait I'm gonna get a
good shot on him
hey I got one ah boom I did it oh yes
Jesus i titled me I hit turd Ferguson
guys turned off and killed me
yeah sure I need a hospital
I'm on fire putting out the fleur-de-lis
alright okay that's it I think they're
on the ship
yes I think we've been bird AddThis oh
my god we acquire all got our sales are
on fire
alright that's not good yeah I just I'm
dying
oh I'm dead too I'm killing zone by zone
ha ha ha ha maan
[ __ ] sake get got but I'm in the water
now [ __ ] is the [ __ ] hole at how do I
know who are pirates and who were
enemies oh there's a British rifle skin
the British people wear white and blue
shirts and stuff and pirates wear like
no shirts or like pirate shirts okay
really explains it hello friends see see
- - - for now
but not today I'm [ __ ] I push you were
issued on a non-fire you got the boat
out goddamn pumps I'm dead hahahaha Bob
what did you get it into Oh people are
it's just you pirate [ __ ] ya know a lion
but it's a boy I love the head it how do
I load a cannon who the hell is a good
guy who that's kind of got to be a bad
guy yeah all right well hahaha
wait dead now my airship yeah we could
jump on their [ __ ] I'll still like twice
Oh Jack who is twice as loud as Marc
alright yeah well that sounds like a you
problem
yeah oh wow I was John I don't kill they
turd Ferguson not about your life if you
are you we're on different teams wait
you guys went to the British no we're on
pirates I'm on pirate - turd Ferguson
run a gray shirt no turd fur and is on
the British side oh those boys what I
died nearly we're sinking things we're
not solving takes a load of gun while
you're on there's a lot of steps
it's pirate o'clock Oh turn around with
a box
I killed a camper Oh a camper ah I I
think that's I think that's a dude wait
blub you're showing that order you're
not even on our team yeah I'm trying to
help you wait Oh [ __ ] blue
I am just watching kindly from the
background job I was just watching I'd
have a good time
you mom Laurie oh no it's gone
oh we win hey we're out of here [ __ ]
happened where are everything
we're leaving that's where our
everything you do yeah there's a corpse
just floating on our mask they're hot I
might be seeing things too much grog and
well this guy I'm driving apparently
that's my body oh okay all right then
are you the captain would know oh I
don't look damaged signs up there oh you
call you know I'm up the outside of the
cookie just like real pirates I know I
got the fasted how do I talk in this
game how do I talk in game like the same
as all the other way I turned it off oh
no boat boat come back oh these need to
be captain because it will not let me
captain man overboard you asshat all
right so this crows masks on [ __ ] I
can't see [ __ ] kind of a sailor my way
Sokolow don't mind me I live life here
just try to live oh you wanna write holy
[ __ ] we're 12 rare oh and I'm gonna get
oh [ __ ] do you see the other guns in
here the duck foot patch yeah over
walking wrap one oh my god God yeah
they're not going to particular what a
duck foot the [ __ ] is awesome bad
naughty inspire the front cannon I'm
ramming this cannon guys is their enemy
I hit the sail the [ __ ] around man
where
oh hey all right you ha ha we're how do
we change that all there behind rear gun
young no luck right now oh you think we
are I think we are I think you are and
you are how does that I felt it up in
yourself the swivel guns are designed to
hit the field
okay can you ever cut off my gun this is
my girl you could change the mo in the
main gun lining of it so just right now
I'm angry
Oh damaged enemy ship good boy good boy
good boy
oh I wish I hit you five e to power how
do we patch this you kiss ha ha shoot me
ha ha ha oh this is not a gun I don't
know I killed one of your [ __ ] first
guy got ha ha ha I just saw a shower of
blood those nuts we're getting this one
ellos this knows good I was on the same
thing that'd be hammer my mom I'm gonna
mash your hammer oh [ __ ] yeah she's
looking away
Kotler seem to be taking on water
oh it's a friendly get it oh my friend
oh [ __ ] oh me you're speaking very fast
Oh God oh that ago I have a present for
you Mike Eric says that I have a present
for you
whole whole arias manner all right how
do we pump yeah there's a show you the
middle lever around you have to go and
pump on the pump levers yeah we got a I
thought the bottom of the room let's
stop company yeah we got to fix the
holes first and then pump and then we're
good boys I know below decks
I'm ramen D whose boys are you talking
about our boys are doing better than
your boy oh boy oh boy your company
about how boys are doing hey Oh boys are
the right Angus boys Wow my face bad
laughing ha ha ha ha I got my animal
coming pointment
I want to do like a sniper shot I want
to do like a [ __ ] noscope or
something you gotta you gotta you gotta
get the musket out bro or should I have
I know how to pirate okay our stuff is
all ready to go but we're not lined up
wait there's something else behind us
what is this boink
[Applause]
we did I dunno what the hell happy what
we were doing
ya heard Ferguson bad my dad 100 what he
was I was 26 I was 122 fire code pirates
try and join fire okay trying to get
parts Oh [ __ ] ship oh we got to
join mother [ __ ] mother fire oh hell
we gotta join the mother core we're all
in we rollin rollin rollin hell yeah I
need to turn you down a bit I'm not I
don't want to be carrying someone else
be captain I know dial to be captain I
know to focus to be captain go figure
I'm a motor focus alright low load all
the cannons [ __ ] up the
[ __ ] ship ah now we know what
you love a good ridership [ __ ]
[ __ ] me ass
Oh barry mccockiner my god [ __ ] man in
charge I can't even see what's happening
so this is not the entire round Oh
the [ __ ] gonna stay here yes
you know [ __ ] your father it's not an
athlete all the common oh yeah you
scurvy dog these are small kings or the
cannons you come why are we a Chinese
specific Wow
why didn't we get the big ship guys what
I'm feeling about this voila
call me Lord better only nighty nighty
nighty day I won failed the ocean off
the front left people off the front off
the front left and then I get a looker
I'm ready I'm ready
hey fire oh oh yeah damn it anyway
if they start boarding us get your guns
and [ __ ] out and fight fight them alive
anything I can yeah oh god it's when USS
Trump guys oh god everything how do I be
huge oh actually it's a tiny hands easy
to miss out Trump jokes okay Trump jokes
hashtag nailed it that's a tiny hand
that's a where are we [ __ ] crazy
I don't know be firing firing the right
side fire off the right side
oh right side on both sides I'll reload
I'll reload go unload mark I wasn't
using I wasn't using nautical terms the
right side is still just the right side
even though the right one was right mean
yeah well do any I can reload the
cannons out here with that right okay
shut up I'm trying her don't yell at my
pirate harder really never I want to ram
it at all I need positive reinforcement
all right I feel like this is a hostile
working very mark your shuttle snowflake
and you can do it buddy good job okay I
feel better and I love that [ __ ] alright
right side oh no left side come out well
we're gonna [ __ ] ran these guys on
our backup oh yeah they're single good
for your outside play and firing desire
I hit him haha hit down her in there how
they [ __ ] miss point-blank yeah how
did I not get a hit for that I don't
know it in yeah I thought I got a hit
for that I don't know oh my facebook on
toys what of all supplies we need
resupplies and I pray the light and [ __ ]
and [ __ ] fire
alright then how am I not how am I not
where's the hole i I don't get that I'm
not getting hit Oh apparently I bled
yeah it's [ __ ] sinking faster than
your mother my mother stinky where's my
mom Wow
I'm going on my dick what one sorry mud
to see it gets to me she speaks to me
and tells me what to say guys i
mothership I got a broken bottle I'm
ready for oh yeah [ __ ] get him I
don't think anybody's alive on this ship
I hate guys I'm trapped under ship I
died okay I was outside trying to run
down Mikey probably loves him
it's a tiny boat we're fine yeah I was
trying to fake where's the hole as crazy
as it is it's actually really fun yeah
no I know right it's like we're actually
pirates are your is that an enemy over
there
we're not anywhere from 40 mm per second
we can hit though make fire off the run
oh I had a light fight right side right
side
yeah what's outer all right guys
buffered upper you can't have all that
cannon all right I'm gonna try Bardem
we're mobilizing Oh gonna hit somebody -
no no [ __ ] that dude oh where I take my
dog I would oh boy honey fix the nose hi
guys I'm going over there ow
I'm going over did you duck hahahahahaha
mother dude get back here no I'm gonna
kill him alright um oh wait you really
got to kill those guys you really gotta
you really got to get those have a
grenade sir
you want a grenade here you go right by
your face my thinking with the enemy
ship again yeah I died does anyone else
fix [ __ ] on the phone I'm getting right
ha ha ha we got I went over there and I
serger native there captain eaten then
the ship went I mean that sounds like a
like a solid effort buddy you know what
I like I like your thinking it would
have blown up she's done that's a real
that's the real stress you got there
whoo nice maneuvering yeah this one
guy's got some maneuvers yeah I am
around the moon you can reach a
[ __ ] oh my [ __ ] already
in Marshall Davis are they behind us why
we're going to save the hms swag wait
oldest of the whole time I'm not hurting
weight wagons fire somebody there's a
there's a British ship directly in front
of us sinking Neverland oh right there
yeah no don't leave me
see ya I give you an island off I'll
throw you wrote me yeah kill be an enemy
in the waters well there's two enemies
okay now we're getting our new possum
Adam I'm gonna forward guys I see one
he's completely booked never mind he
died where is Mark it's mommy's way
behind us now on the right side coming
around this island there should be some
more guys to shoot them alright your
army my booty there be hmm oh good
pirate ah Quaid you really get me I'm
not when I got some guys Oslo welcome oh
yeah your wizard day huh I got sail
damage I don't even know what I'm firing
it but you got built it makes your fire
their sails by that logic uh yeah we
have this one here on the pirate
longneck see bad guys bad guys bad guys
that guys I'm on I'm on the roof hit hey
hey okay I'm ready to [ __ ] I'm about to
[ __ ] them up
come another fall where are the motors
groan hard
here we go baby here we go baby here
we're gonna be ramming the ramming Oh
direction on track oh my god
if they ram us get ready for get ready
for boarding and firing I've been bad
again whoops Nick marker I can fell yes
that's British over there welcome up
they're starting to move now lead them
oh nice life oh no you died sorry not
not as nice no yeah I got I got the guy
who killed you
I have edged you my friend thanks you
Bob I love you
I think I'm bleeding out oh my god Wayne
you just like vomited blood and we don't
really like a hose and your guy was like
ah this all over I'm hitting their sales
as much as I can
oh we got more holes okay for some holes
all right again you know name-calling
gets nobody nowhere you know what I'm
saying the holes friends that I love
there we cook now I want to fix fix a
whole bubble
I respect there we go that's better
that's okay that's nice good job good
pumping buddy feel like we're another
[ __ ]
I got the whole guy the whole other
Walker pump it so good
well tacking on water like it just takes
a minute you're doing it you're doing
you know if you enunciate I might be
able to understand what you're trying to
talk that's a little better I think
that's a bit too far away to be fire nut
I know but they're perfect within sales
I'm at range
they're perfect for flirting you oh God
morning ma'am oh no I'm not
apparently I'm not gonna start work at
the back of the head oh you didn't I'm
good guys you don't you don't worry
buddy - you got one got one okay Oh yuck
footing it's for [ __ ] bath I'm very
oh my god had done nothing like three
minutes to reload for mr. ready hey I
killed him overnight I'm here whoa Oh
she'll die tomorrow
barded we're getting barded I said
la bete if he said everybody was oh [ __ ]
oh my god I was shot in the head guys oh
oh look oh there's it's all black oh my
god they boarded us so hurry to taste
oh yeah well get come on it I'm in the
water I'm on fire I'm always blowing you
[ __ ] up with my grenade wait am I the
only one in the market
hello okay friends yeah
[Music]